WE EXPECT A LOT OF ACTION.
FIRST, THE RACE TO RADICALISM,
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
FOR ANY OF YOU WHO HAD THE
MISFORTUNE OF CATCHING EVEN A
FEW MINUTES OF THE DEMOCRAT
DEBATE LAST NIGHT, YOU'LL
UNDOUBTEDLY AGREE THAT IT WAS A
GREAT NIGHT FOR DONALD TRUMP.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF PERHAPS A
CANDIDATE NO ONE KNOWS, KELSEY
GABBARD, WHAT'S CLEAR IS THAT
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY HAS LEARNED
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING SINCE 2016.
THEY COMPLETELY MISREAD THE
RESULTS OF LAST ELECTION AND
HAVE ADOPTED ESSENTIALLY A SLASH
AND BURN STRATEGY TOWARDS ALMOST
EVERY AMERICAN TRADITION AND
COMMON SENSE UNDERSTANDING OF
ECONOMICS AND GOVERNANCE.
IT'S MOST ENTERTAINING, I THINK,
IF WE BREAK DOWN THE CURRENT
DEMOCRAT GLOOMINESS
INTO SEVERAL MOMENTS.
FIRST, THE MONEY GROWS ON TREES
MENTALITY.
>> MY PLAN WOULD BE FIRST F
>> MY PLAN WOULD BE FIRST R
>> MY PLAN WOULD BE FIRST T
>> MY PLAN WOULD BE FIRST O
>> MY PLAN WOULD BE FIRST F
>> MY PLAN WOULD BE FIRST A
>> MY PLAN WOULD BE FIRST L
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE FREE.
>> WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FOR
FREE COLLEGE, FREE PUBLIC
COLLEGE, FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
>> UNIVERSAL CHILD CARE FOR
EVERY BABY AGES ZERO TO FIVE
PURITY UNIVERSAL.
A TECHNICAL SCHOOL, TO YOUR
COLLEGE AND FOR YOUR COLLEGE FOR
EVERYBODY WHO WANTS TO GIVE IT A
TRY.
>> WE SHOULD GIVE EVERYONE IN
THIS COUNTRY HEALTH CARE AS A
BASIC HUMAN RIGHT FOR FREE.
FULL STOP.
>> HEALTH CARE IS NOT JUST A
HUMAN RIGHT, IT SHOULD BE AN
AMERICAN RIGHT AND I BELIEVE THE
BEST WAY TO GET THERE IS
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
>> I BELIEVE MEDICARE FOR ALL IS
THE WAY TO DO THAT.
>> Laura: REMEMBER, SPEND NOW,
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO PAY FOR IT
ALL LATER.
THEY STILL THINK THERE'S ENOUGH
RICH PEOPLE TO COVER TRILLIONS
AND TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN NEW
SPENDING.
I'D LIKE TO GO BACK AND SEE THE
GRADES OF THESE PEOPLE AND WHAT
THEY GOT AN ECONOMIC 101.
IF THEY EVEN TOOK ECONOMICS AT
ALL.
THEN THERE IS WHAT I CALL THE
DISCONNECTED FROM REALITY
CAUCUS.
AT A TIME WHEN 71% AMERICANS ARE
HAPPY WITH THE ECONOMY,
DEMOCRATS HAVE BLINDERS ON.
>> WE KNOW THAT NOT EVERYONE IS
SHARING IN HIS PROSPERITY.
>> I THINK OF IT THIS WAY.
WHO IS THIS ECONOMY REALLY
WORKING FOR?
>> THIS ECONOMY HAS GOT TO WORK
FOR EVERYONE.
AND RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THAT IT
ISN'T.
I SEE EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT THIS
ECONOMY IS NOT WORKING FOR
AVERAGE AMERICANS.
>> Laura: YOU GET THE
REPETITION.
NOT WORKING FOR EVERYONE.
U.S. IS ABOUT TO EXPERIENCE THE
LONGEST ECONOMIC EXPANSION ON
RECORD AND THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
IS AT ITS LOWEST IN NEARLY 50
YEARS ACROSS MOST DEMOGRAPHICS.
BUT SHORT, THE ECONOMY ISN'T
WORKING.
GO WITH THAT, DEMOCRATS.
BUT DON'T WORRY, BECAUSE THEY
ALWAYS HAVE THEIR FAVORITE
ASSORTMENT OF CLICHES AND
BROMIDES TO CHOOSE FROM.
>> WE NEED TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
HAS A LIVING WAGE.
>> IMMIGRANTS, THEY DO NOT
DIMINISH AMERICA, THEY ARE
AMERICA.
>> DIVERSITY IS A STRENGTH.
>> EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Laura: OKAY, WHETHER THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE IT PUBLICLY OR NOT,
THE DAMS NOW KNOW, AND EVERYONE
ON STAGE KNEW THAT MOST
AMERICANS THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS ACCOMPLISHED A HECK OF A LOT
IN HIS FIRST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS, FROM TRADE DEALS TO THE
ECONOMY.
FROM JUDGES TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
SO THIS MEANS THAT THEY HAVE TO
CONVINCE YOU THAT THEY'LL GET
MORE DONE.
>> THREE THINGS TO KNOW ABOUT
ME.
FIRST, I LISTEN TO PEOPLE, AND
THAT'S HOW I GET THINGS DONE.
>> I'M ONE OF THE FEW CANDIDATES
IN THIS RACE WITH EXECUTIVE
EXPERIENCE, WITH A TRACK RECORD
OF GETTING THINGS DONE.
>> I THINK WE NEED TO GET THINGS
DONE.
>> Laura: AT LEAST DELANEY HAS
IN FACT DONE SOMETHING IN
BUSINESS.
OTHERWISE IT'S CANDIDATES COMING
UNDONE.
BY THE TIME THE SNOOZER LAPTOP
TO MY STOMACH WRAPPED UP, EVEN
THE LIBERAL MSNBC HAD TO ADMIT
THAT SOMETHING WAS WRONG.
>> I'M A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED.
I THINK WE NEEDED TO HAVE MORE
DISCUSSION ON THOSE ISSUES THAT
ACTUALLY AFFECTED AMERICANS
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> de BLASIO IS MILDLY
IRRITATING TO ME.
>> THERE CERTAINLY ARE SOME
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
THAT WOULD BE GREAT CANDIDATES.
>> YOU HAVE TO GET RID OF
DONALD TRUMP IF YOU'RE GOING TO
DO ANY OF THE STUFF, IF YOU'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT ANY OF THESE
ISSUES IN ITS
REASONABLE-SOUNDING WAY.
>> I STILL IN MY HEART OF HEARTS
DON'T SEE ANYONE ON THAT STAGE
TONIGHT THAT WOULD BEAT TRUMP.
>> Laura: I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M
ACTUALLY GOING TO SAY THIS, AND
PINCHING MYSELF, BUT I AGREE
WITH DONNY.
THE DEMOCRATS LACK SUBSTANCE,
KNOW-HOW, PRAGMATISM, CHARISMA,
CREDIBILITY, AND A CONNECTION TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WELL, THEN THERE WAS THIS
FITTING MOMENT THAT MANY ONLINE
JOKES WAS KIND OF A WINK FROM ON
HIGH.
>> EVERYBODY'S MICS ARE ON.
I THINK WE HAVE A -- I HEARD
THAT TOO.
>> CONTROL THEM, WE HAVE --
>> WE HAVE THE AUDIENCE AUDIO.
I APOLOGIZE YOU GUYS DIDN'T GET
TO HEAR THIS STUFF.
WE HEARD.
WE ARE HEARING OUR COLLEAGUES
AUDIO.
IF THE CONTROL ROOM COULD TURN
OFF THE MICS OF OUR PREVIOUS
MODERATOR.
>> WE'VE PREPARED FOR
EVERYTHING.
BUT WE DID NOT PREPARE FOR THIS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A QUICK
BREAK.
>> Laura: THE MOST FUN THING
TO DO, BY THE WAY IT WAS TO READ
THE TRANSCRIPT AND HERE ARE THE
UNDERLYING -- IT HAPPENS, IS
TELEVISION.
CAN'T DUMP ON THEM FOR THAT.
THE DEMOCRATS THOUGH HAVE BEEN
ON A PERPETUAL BREAK SINCE 2016
AND NOT A COMMERCIAL BREAK, A
BREAK FROM REALITY.
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
LIKELY LET THEM STAY IN HER
ULTIMATE UNIVERSE WHERE
SOCIALISM WORKS AND YOU NEVER
RUN OUT OF OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY.
AND A RATINGS NOTE, THIS VERSE
DEMOCRAT DEBATE RATED LOWER THAN